[Music]
all right in chores for sex news this is
submitted by I scream for ice cream
right the Instagram store is under fire
for joking that our husband only does
housework to get lucky I thought that
was like an old thing should be banned
from the platform wait so she's joking
about it he's joking about it say I
think she jokes about oh yeah so this um
this chick by the way I would gladly do
the dishes for a [ __ ] I mean not even
a question
yep like I don't even have any oh I
don't even have any objections about
that and if the seat was empty I'll just
wash the sink if there's sink was empty
I throw a bunch of dishes and if it was
that easy that's awesome yeah yeah so
this chick her name is Bree her IG has
seventy four point six thousand
followers and so she posted this photo
with her husband and it says helping
with housework so you can get lucky is
called choreplay
that's funny kind of cute I think it's
really offensive and yeah it hurts my
feelings you're right you should never
use sex as a weapon she's [ __ ] up dude
she's using her vagina against him and
we should all be outraged walk move
yeah she's pimping him to do chores
right
how dare she do that how could she
people are actually offended for a
different reason
Oh what is it try to be with the point
right now oh really
we're not woken up
okay
I try to welcome this is offended
mentality what is it what does it say it
says helping with housework so you can
get lucky is called chore play and then
her captions Oh her caption said I know
what it is the people that like the word
for play got mad because they have a new
word called choreplay that's gonna
replace sorry caption said uh nothing
hotter any other acts of service love
language errs out their mind 100% he
does he doesn't do anything at home ever
our people mad because she's basically
forcing him to do chores to have sex or
people are mad that would be exactly
what you just said before man maybe
because the guy is
she's sexualizing him okay no one here
is woken up I don't know anyone I guess
I wait wait maybe I'm looking at this
all wrong I want to try one more time he
wouldn't do tours unless the sex was is
it is it okay that he doesn't do chores
that she's okay with that you think you
are upset yeah yeah like it's like wait
what it's not fifty-fifty
yeah like Oh like he doesn't do any
housework and it's just all left on her
eyes she has pretty much what does it
really mean you won though cuz that
means more the most you are the workers
yeah I had to go there I to go really
sensitive lowest-common-denominator
Harley yeah yeah yeah I'm like what do I
[ __ ] what do [ __ ] how do they
feels like one example right you know
what I wasn't even thinking about like
if it was men or women getting angry
yeah yeah so this someone edited the
photo to include helping with housework
because a fair and equal equitable
equitable anything that equitable
equitable okay because a fair and
equitable division of labor is just and
right is called being a grown-ass man
hmm yes God you think a lot of fun
doesn't that mean that they're
projecting gender roles because they
think that women can do all the work so
they're okay so the reason why rapido
because they're saying that what she's
portraying is something very
old-fashioned that the guy like oh man
if he does any housework at all then
that's a foreplay because that just
turns me on so much and so he's only
gonna he's only gonna help around the
house because he knows he's gonna get
sex out of it instead of this should be
a 50/50 house
coold like you know you also live here
so you should be doing housework as well
so that's what people are saying those
people are projecting their [ __ ]
[ __ ] on this because she even said
in the post she gets turned on by acts
of service so could be it could be
whatever the [ __ ] but for her when he
does chores it turns her on
so they're going like oh no it's this
1950s mentality like only the women do
the housework and if he does even a
little bit he should get a gold star but
she just said that this turns her on
thank you I think people need to really
just realize that is it this this
Instagram yeah she she has 74,000
follows not 76 million like is this it's
[ __ ] Instagram and it could be a joke
like she's not writing a book about it
goes on behind closed doors
yeah you could be cleaning everything
this went viral because someone took her
her photo and then post it on Twitter
with the caption influencers must be
stopped like we're a plague
yeah so then someone replied to her
tweet saying only Monica from friends
could get away with saying this and
that's because she's not real and even
then Chandler would have one of his
serious moments and say I'm not just
helping with the housework I live here
too were a team Chandler would
definitely say that that's definitely a
Chandler response but the fact that it's
got to this level that we had to bring
other fictional characters into it shows
how ridiculous Instagram do it exactly
and then you're gonna you make the
Chandler post and then somebody's like
why is it gonna be Chandler Rachel was
pretty cool yeah I do
believe in 5050 at our house I mow half
of the line and then she mows the other
half of it that's good and then even the
toilet seat we start white you come here
and we clean all the way until you meet
in the middle over the toilet bowl while
we're doing it yeah that's how you do it
that's it I call this it is never up cuz
I I sit down when I pee but then I [ __ ]
out what I stand up when I [ __ ] me too
so it's kind of a mess
cleaning up but she doesn't mind cuz she
appreciates that I never likely the
toilet it up so another one love
language if he's only doing it to get
sex for home gosh that's what you do all
of it for that's what life is about
that is all of the love languages so you
don't argue and you can get sex that's
what the love everything is a balance
I bet this person is like not married in
like under 25 cents a stupid [ __ ] like
that
I was all about the person that they
responded about that the whole love
language things like you been to met
together for someone for over five years
you know what sets him off you know what
you don't want to argue about so
whatever I can do to keep you from to
shut the [ __ ] up I'm gonna shut the [ __ ]
up out of this situation so good so yes
I know you like random acts of kindness
okay who I got you some shoes and I cook
dinner yeah yeah and then maybe [ __ ]
right cuz yeah right so yes that's what
you do for the [ __ ] and have no
arguments i all about the Internet is
just a lecture circuit it's just like
whatever you post is up for review
constantly and we all have to accept the
terms or not another tweet says what the
[ __ ]
lol helping with housework stop teaching
women that if men do housework it's
helping and they should get rewarded
they aren't children it's 50% of their
responsibility is this person oh man
this is [ __ ] crazy we are children
actually and it's acts of service dude
like Nicky [ __ ] loves it when I do
housework and she [ __ ] treats me like
a real good boy when I do it
that's not like I'm a child sure does
but guess what it had made it
incentivizes me to do housework and I
got this high and that's their flirting
you know it's it's kind of like saying
like some girls like to get slapped
around and called names during sex but I
mean is that abuse a woman never wants
to be slapped around yeah yeah but these
[ __ ] do outside the beer when we call
a [ __ ] right I would never choke a
woman outside of the bedroom
unless we're [ __ ] in the bathroom
[Laughter]
yeah so god these people are so boring
oh they think Zoey's thing I want to
meet these kind of people though cuz
they only exist on the internet and I
don't know no they exist in real life
but they're really good about being
passive-aggressive or just kind of being
fate
yeah well you don't so we might know
them but we don't know that we've
encountered them a lot but really we
feel them over like never been in a
relationship like a real relationship
before a long-term life yeah not a real
one listen real marriage is [ __ ]
with the door open while I talk about
why the beg explains the flame it'll
break it down so when you go to the
bathroom in front of your lady yes or
your man uh-huh you're slowly degrading
your relationship because you're not
seen as a sexual being to them
I see when she's naked [ __ ] she's
still sexually I'm pretty [ __ ]
holiday no I don't think she's just to
call your friend anything is there you
just took a [ __ ] and left the street
mark I would still [ __ ] the [ __ ] out of
her
I'm not saying that you wouldn't do it
after that I'm talking about over time
man Michael like water on rocks okay
it's just party of the relationship yeah
every time he smells my [ __ ] he goes oh
my god and I see a boner yeah we all
know that bart has some issues
[Laughter]
oh he doesn't think that everybody fight
wait wait wait wait so y'all ready can't
[ __ ] in front of you because of the
deteriorate no it's a vice-versa
it's a Bo fee I don't I don't do
anything in front of her and what you
pee on her and you eat the but I'll pee
on her that was a bit oh I don't I don't
but I would I'm not against me you
haven't even eaten the but little and
face to face the but with the cat and
you know what your dad wasn't a pimp so
we're even
I told you that in confidence you
bastard people watching it that's right
you go find a consistency is gonna be a
ball whilst they [ __ ] all of those
things I disagree with it I think the
video should be honored that's why yes
Jess thank you
that's my no that's my suggestion box
[ __ ] Steve no that's the nude by my
weight because the bathroom bang yeah no
not because of the bathroom because you
lied to him yeah you lied to me man the
but only because our piss brothers will
go I'll get you them back to this and
I'll text you after heat the butt later
okay okay i'ma hold you do it with my
number right now hey I wanted to do it I
wanted to do you can't you can't you
can't wait for the perfect time you just
got it you got to catch it like what she
gets out of the shower she's is land
cellophane like cool off this is going
at its prime too cheesy don't then don't
don't [ __ ] [ __ ] foot around the
[ __ ] just go right in don't don't
don't stick your tongue in it's not a
[ __ ] like you're not searching for
something for cocking like yeah and then
around the hole you just ran round the
red what about a little what's called
arena pinky and I'm not two people under
this thing that's weak that's only door
sex that you do that that was the
meaning okay yeah it's just just you
want to just graze it right no
feathering it was all wet don't get a
sloppy just get a little wet your
LeBlanc Wow
can I ask then what name like you like
some more there as you like yeah I will
you keep going
where does it go though what turns on oh
there's a push the nipples I stick it in
yeah but then it doesn't so it doesn't
it doesn't turn into anal it turns into
vaginal this help like the story is
helping listen and then give it a little
bump
it's like a [ __ ] battery to a car you
have to clap on the tune and you guys
sticking the key yeah you ride the
Tydeus motorcycle
[Music]
[Music]